there are a number of historic victories
in this midterm election including have
you heard this
the first two muslim women elected to
congress
democrat rashida talib we did a story on
her one of seton michigan's 13th
district congrats to her
and democrat ilhan omar triumphed in
minnesota's fifth district
with 78 percent of the vote go you omar
will be the first
somali-american and the first woman of
color from minnesota
in the house of representatives she
joins us now from minneapolis
for her very first interview as
representative elect
ilhan omar shall we say congresswoman
omar how do you like the sound of that
sounds really amazing how are you good
morning to you guys i am really good
what message do you hope that your
victory sends this morning
to the country other than that you're a
bad mamma jamma what do you want us to
get out of this
that it's a beautiful morning it's a new
start
um you know here in minnesota it's a
cold state but the people have warm
hearts and we don't just welcome
immigrants
but we send them to washington so it's a
beautiful morning
you are the first also the first refugee
elected
to congress and i know you've done a lot
in your state to help refugees
is there a message you hope to bring to
washington when you represent your
district in congress
yeah um you know it's going to be a
really great opportunity for me to
represent
the values and and the interest of uh
people
in the fifth we have a huge community
here who is very much invested in making
sure that minnesota and
our whole country is a welcoming place
for refugees and immigrants
and i hope to bring a unique insight
to the lives and the struggles that
refugees lead
and the kind of opportunities and hope
they're looking for once they come here
what is a top legislative priority for
you going forward
so here in the fifth uh while we were
campaigning we heard
all the time how unfortunate it is
really
in this country for people to uh fi
to have to file for bankruptcy because
they get sick
we hear all the time from students
who are struggling with the shackles of
student debt
and we are hearing from working families
across our district
who are feeling burdened by the fact
that
this economy isn't fully working for
them and
our politics and policies are centering
them
on what is your view of president trump
there's a lot of questions about whether
new democrats coming to washington are
going to be anxious to work with the
president or whether they
feel that the way he talked about the
caravan or other issues created the
conditions uh to make
america uh different than they would
like to see it what's your view
our uh concert our founding fathers
really created the constitution so that
we have
different branches of government that
are
designed to be a check on themselves and
my hope
is that the new congress is going to
serve as a check
to the rhetoric of fear and division and
destruction
and make sure that we are moving the
country in the direction that the people
have asked us for
in a direction that is more hopeful
inclusive
and prosperous for all of us ilhan
there's never been anybody like you
from your district going to congress or
in congress or in congress
exactly right so i'm curious what made
you think you could do it and what made
you
want to do it so when i was coming
um to this country i i heard about its
promises
and it wasn't long before i arrived
that i noticed that a lot of uh
america's promise wasn't extended to
everyone
and as i would complain um to to my
grandfather he would say
every progress this country ever
achieved came about because people were
willing to do something
to make that progress happen and so i
knew
early on that if i wanted a different
kind
of neighborhood a different kind of city
and a state
and a country i had to be part of doing
that
and uh in this time in our
nation's history i couldn't sit on the
sidelines and not be part of
a group of people who were insisting on
a set of values that got us closer
to the america we know we can have in
the america we know we deserve
well your message resonated 78 of the
vote that's pretty good congrats
and congresswoman elect omar thank you
so much for being with us
and welcome from the sidelines on to the
field